NBA insider from ESPN Brian Wynn Horst
how are you Brian was there an NFL draft
oh now hold on a second where did you
take it in at all at any part yeah I
mean I'm from Cleveland of course I took
in the first hour and a half okay so
what do you think of the Mayfield pick
Brian well you know I'm Ohio State fan
more than anything else okay I am NOT a
football analyst but here's what I can
tell you yes
Ohio State has a lot of professionals on
their defense sure do
Baker Mayfield came into their building
kicked their ass against the full team
and when they played Sam d'Arnaud on a
neutral field without the number four
overall pick who sat out the game which
I don't blame them for Denzel Ward he
didn't and so I'm just gonna base it on
that I can't say what happened in the
meetings I can't say but a throwing
technique and all that stuff I just know
I watch Baker kicked my teams behind and
I watch my team kicks and Arnold behinds
that's all that's my that's okay that's
the the NFL Draft analysis through this
scarlet and gray prism of Brian Wynn
horse so what did you make of LeBrons
comments that he was exhausted burnt I
thought it was just a human response
others are obviously as always reading
other things into what LeBron is saying
what do you think Brian i I just he he
gave more effort in that series and just
about any other series in his career and
it's just talk about robbing from Peter
to pay Paul to get through this series
you know LeBron had cramps in that game
he's had cramps two or three other times
in his career he once told me that
regular season sweats and playoffs went
are different it's just when you play in
a playoff game it takes more out of you
and he has cramps when he gets exhausted
and those have happened in later rounds
you know a couple times have them in the
finals I think once I'm adapted in the
second round the fact he got cramps in
the game which is one of his biggest
enemies is just an it shows me that it
may only be technically a second-round
series but I feel like he's used to
serious worth of energy already and if
the cab are gonna have any chance and I
will say this I do think the matchup
against Toronto favoured them more than
the matchups against Indiana there's
certain advantages they didn't have in
us in the end like what but they can't
well the the Indiana big men I don't
know how much you want glasses no the
Indiana big men are very versatile and
they gave the Cavs a lot of problems be
the Toronto big men you know they're
more you know traditional you know they
have power forward they have centers and
the Cavs have been able to isolate Serge
Ibaka and really run him ramped it with
Kevin Love playing Center during the
regular season in fact they beat them
twice in the last three weeks of the
season they they beat him twice and they
have a history of beating them in the
playoffs they beat in the last two years
so I think there's there's some slight
advantages but if the Cavs continue to
try to get 40 points from abroad every
single game he's just not going to last
it has nothing to do with him it has to
do with simple mechanics of the body and
and to have them have to turn around and
play a game tomorrow a game one a huge
advantage for Toronto this happened the
opposite direction
two years ago Toronto played a
seven-game series with the with the
Miami Heat had to come in for the
Eastern Conference Finals on a one day
arrest when Cleveland had some time
because Cleveland had taken care of
their business because they were a
better team and a higher seed and I
think the Raptors lost the first two
games but I could combine 50 points and
so that's the kind of shoe on the other
foot situation that the Cavs have going
into Toronto tomorrow and the the
emphasis that they put on LeBron is
unsustainable I think everybody would
agree with that
so did Tristan Thompson play himself
into some meaningful minutes what do you
think so could be interesting rich
because again matchup wise the way the
Cavs played the Raptors in the regular
season they put Kevin Love at center and
they ran the Raptors rampant and ran
Ibaka all over the court and spread the
floor and Toronto who has one of the
great defenses in the NBA couldn't stop
the cab I think the one game they played
in March I want to say the final score
was like 131 127 they completely took
the Raptors apart defense was that
playing small so if they carry over the
the game plans they using the
regular-season Tristan Thompson would
not be a big part of it that said
the reasons why Tristan Thompson had to
play was because Kevin Love was getting
massively outplayed by every single
Pacers big man and it was a you know a
borderline strategy move a borderline
desperation move which is not an insult
I mean a coach should be desperate game
seven but because you know rich the Cavs
started thirty-three different lineups
in the regular season far and away the
most LeBrons ever had even though he
played nollie - he was in all 33 they
started four different lineups in the
seven games of the first round now
granted they had an injury to George
Hill but I mean the consistency from
game to game is non-existent for this
team so it's very hard for me to even
predict what they're gonna do much less
tyloo nobody's gonna get from players
from you know Sunday to Tuesday Brian
went Horst here on the Rich Eisen show
asked the ESPN NBA insider our poll
question Chris yeah Brian who's the
favorite to come out of the East right
now Philly Cleveland Toronto boss what
do you think I think it's Toronto
because the Raptors did some things in
this series with the Wizards that
they've never done before first off they
won a game one they'd lost nine straight
game one was one of the most bizarre
streaks in the NBA number two in Game
five they were behind in the fourth
quarter in a pressure situation but that
team the last few years would have
folded and that's in those moments and
they not only rose up in one they won
going away and then they were behind in
the second half in Washington on Friday
and they came and won that game they are
showing signs that they are moving on as
a team and they're gonna have home court
advantage no I understand that everybody
is on Philly and certainly I recognize
that they're doing a great job and they
have sort of a magical run I mean they
didn't get a lot of breaks for a while
with all the injuries everything was
going their way right now in fact look
at tonight Jalen Brown is probably not
going to play I don't even know if he's
officially been declared out he's
doubtful so they're gonna play Boston in
my mind without three or four best
players I mean if there's an opportunity
to steal home court this is it in Boston
coming off a seven game series just 24
hours rest this is it everything is
going to Philly's way but I do believe
at some point they will hit some
adversity and I
see how they adjust to that and
typically you don't see young players
make it all in one fell swoop so I think
Toronto but it's not like I feel like
it's overwhelming favorite I do think
we're gonna see it's a really good
couple of series here and want to see
how it all plays out all right Brian
Wynn Horst I'm gonna put you in a sports
talk radio box meaning you can only
answer the question I'm about to give
you which could have about in ten
different shades of nuance to it you may
only answer it one or two ways okay so
you have a choice in order for Russell
Westbrook to win it all he must a modify
his game B get a better supporting cast
I mean I think that the Thunder
underachieved this year so and I don't
think was related with supporting cast I
don't know if if everyone I don't know
if anyone's figured out how to use
Russell Westbrook properly yet or at
least get him onto the onto the right
page I think Scott Brooks is a really
good coach I think Billy Donovan is a
really good coach I don't think it's a
matter of a coach not knowing how to do
it I think he's a challenging player and
I think he has you know he has things to
learn about himself and you know there's
still challenges to learn how to play it
you know there haven't been many players
like this in NBA history there's not a
guidebook like how you how do you play
it but this was a disappointing season
for them I I do believe that they had a
personality where they were going to be
a really good defensive team and then
Andre Roberson got hurt and they chased
their tail on trying to fill that role
and everything and then Carmelo Anthony
was nowhere near the player they thought
he would be so those two things changed
the the arithmetic for them and but that
happens in the season you have injuries
you have things that unexpected it was
not it was not good for them to lose
that first-round series even though I
thought that the Jazz earned it and
played great so I mean can we safely say
that the Pacers got the better end of
the deal can we safely say that now
Brian well it if get Paul George signed
somewhere else
you can certainly well no no I you know
I'm but I must let's just assume George
stays seriously I mean playoff P what
happened right I mean I mean yeah I mean
and you know what's the bonus was
terrific
I mean our Depot had a breakout series
after a breakout season and Sabonis had
a great series I think he averaged 12
points and 5 rebounds which as a
secondary piece was terrific he was a
difference maker in a couple of those
games
so yes the Pacers look like they're in
great shape right now all I'm gonna say
is that not even the Pacers knew Oladipo
was going to be this good I mean they
may say that they had an idea and
everything but Oladipo was a product of
time and place and drive and experience
and spending time with Westbrook and
offseason training and I mean it was
amazing it was amazing how fell into
place for them and they're a better team
now and they were so you can certainly
make that argument I still you know Paul
George resides in Oklahoma City you know
let's make the evaluation after you know
2 or 3 years and see where they are but
certainly if you're the Pacers today
sure you're declaring victory but you're
you're you're at home with the Thunder
it's not like you know one of you you
know gotten any farther but the Pacers
have all the people under contract at
less than the max or the next three
years I know that they're very excited
about that
whereas Paul George already told them he
wouldn't resign so that right there is
enough for them to declare victory man
see I just decided to go in this
direction here because it's gonna be
Houston versus Golden State I'm not
mistaken they're correct Brian give me
or give me the best argument against
that yeah I mean I I think both of them
their game ones are pretty damn
impressive and I think if you if you're
if you're looking at the entire league
the way that the the Warriors have
looked in the playoffs so far has been
the reawakening that we thought was
going to happen and they have the
greatest upward mobility because
ding-ding they're bringing a 2000 NDP
back and I expect him to be a major
contributor they look crisp they look
sharp they've gotten tremendous
contributions from down their line up
there one of the things where I thought
they were weak this year is that they
just didn't have as much of a bench in
England Allen wasn't playing well with
Iguodala shut down
Nicko Meritage in Game one and that's
going to be a big matchup issue for the
pelicans so I think the Warriors are
right where they should be and
considering our that's happened to them
I think it's a pretty good situation
and obviously the Rockets are just a
very dangerous team it's gonna be a
tremendous I would love to see cab 76
years because of the LeBron implications
of that series on the east and then to
see Houston Golden State on the west I
don't know if we're gonna get that in
the East like I said I think Toronto
might be the favorite but if that was
our conference final lineup it would be
delicious for two weeks right and with
all due respect to everybody else I
think Adams silver is lighting a candle
for that every single night correct what
did you think well how about my employer
and TNT I mean yesterday's ABC game was
the highest-rated first round game in 14
years okay
I mean with all due respect to Victor
Oladipo the fans weren't turning in to
see that you know they were tuning in to
see LeBron why he could carry this team
it's a very compelling I wish I'm gonna
go so far as to say this if LeBron gets
this team to the final and I really have
a hard time seeing that the way they're
playing right now but okay things could
change if LeBron gets this team of the
finals it will be the second greatest
accomplishment of his career after the
2016 championship and I say that fully
knowing that he won two titles in Miami
I was there for them I know that what
sort of odds he's fighting against right
now he was with his team and everything
that they've got a pill and I don't know
if he can do it but if he does I don't
care if I go the finals and get swept it
would be that sort of level of
accomplishment Brian always enjoy our
chats we will check back in as the NBA
playoffs matriculate
thanks very much appreciate thank you
ready okay Brian you take care that's
Brian one horse to the worldwide leader
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience